[Musique]
mesdames et messieurs bonsoir bienvenue
dans votre émission cette fille débat ce
soir les automobilistes étourdis l'ont
peut-être déjà remarqué en cas de
non-paiement d'une place payante de
l'occupation trop prolongée d'une place
gratuite en zone bleue le pv a été
remplacé par le fps le forfait poste
stationnement la différence depuis le
1er janvier le contrôle du paiement des
places ne dépend plus de la police les
dénés qui en fixe aussi librement le
prix alors stationnement payant quel est
le juste prix c'est le titre de cette
émission
et pour en débattre j'accueille autour
de moi car le livre bonsoir bonsoir
alors vous êtes maire de poissy et vous
avez décidé de fixer le montant de ce
forfait à 35 euros dans votre commune
en face de vous j'accueille if kara
bonsoir vous êtes porte parole de
l'automobile club de france et vous
craignez quelques dérives même si vous
êtes plutôt confiant par rapport à cette
réforme seront centenaire du club
association si je peux me permettre une
association de l'association n'est
devenue une association indépendante et
apolitique
oui non mais d'abord essayer de remettre
du contact vraiment sur ce forfait alors
aujourd'hui le pv nationale qui était
fixée à 17 euros n'est plus là et est
remplacé par mejia de prix comme on peut
voir sur cette carte des yvelines alors
nous pouvons voir que la plupart des
grandes villes ont décidé d'appliquer le
fps sur le territoire et ont pour la
plupart augmenter les prix ça va de 25
euros pour montigny le bretonneux
jusqu'à 35 euros pour poissy petites
exceptions notamment pour rambouillet
qui elle a décidé de baisser de 2 euros
le montant de son forfait
alors on va tout de suite par les
chiffres donc vous avez dit vous décidé
de doubler le mettant du fps sur votre
commune soit deux fois plus que le pv
pourquoi une telle augmentation
déjà je pense qu'il faut pas prendre
cette approche dans ce sens là c'est un
peu l'inversé
parce que prendre cette approche dans ce
sens là c'est donner un peu de caution
finalement parfois aux tricheurs il y en
a 35 euros c'est quoi c'est finalement
une amende ce qui était le cas
auparavant
l'amande qui l'a pas et ceux qui
trichent aujourd'hui ce qu'on a
privilégié apprécié ces deux choses
d'abord avoir un coût horaire à
euro qui est l'un des plus faibles du
département 2 heures à 2 euros est le
message qu'on envoie c'est que nous
souhaitons de la rotation aérienne sur
l'ensemble de la ville de poissy
pourquoi parce que des zones de
chalencon nous avons une zone de
chalandise très importante où il est
compliqué de se garer pendant la journée
alors qu'il existe des possibilités
entre guillemets souterraine avec eux
nos délégations de service public sur
les parkings souterrains qui sont pas
forcément très très bien occupé
donc c'est le message qu'on passe si
vous voulez rester le temps de deux
heures et après si en plus on offre 20
minutes gratuites avec avec les
commerçants quand on vient faire du du
commerce
vous pouvez vous rester la grèce en rien
quelque sorte le matin et si vous
souhaitez rester plus longtemps et bien
dans les parkings souterrains
ça peut vous coûter 4 4 euros les cinq
heures et là encore c'est l'un des prix
les moins les moins importants du
département d'accord donc vous ne vous
considérez pas comme une ville hostile
aux automobilistes et en essayant
d'enlever ou ou abri abritée par par psa
avec ses 7500 employés ce serait un
comble te dire qu'on souhaite
on souhaite bommel usage du véhicule
d'accord de votre côté est ce que vous
êtes rassurés est ce que vous vous dites
ce finalement cette réforme nous a pas
apporté de nous des dérives ou des taxes
supplémentaires pour les automobilistes
c'est la crainte qu'on peut avoir en ce
qui concerne possible trouve que ça va
dans le bon sens d'avoir 20 minutes
alors on pourra voir une heure ou deux
mais bon allez 20 minutes gratuites ça
va dans le bon sens une heure
la première heure deux heures la
première heure c'est plutôt pas mal mais
ce qu'il ya de si on regarde dans un
contexte général pour les automobilistes
mais j'ai envie de dire pour les
français en général parce qu'on est tous
automobilistes soit on a une voiture
personnelle soit on prend celle d'un
autre dans la famille de sa petite
copine aux autres tous les français sont
concernés
c'est que cette mesure qui va encore
pénaliser le portefeuille des français
de toute façon puisque on paiera le
stationnement un petit peu plus serré si
on prend ça justement ça problème c'est
que selon les chiffres de la cour des
comptes notamment ses deux autonomistes
sur trois qui ne payent jamais leur
place de parc sant milk est ce que ce
n'est pas légitime pour les communes
justement d'élever le prix
dès 6 ans dépassent une fois par
automobiliste sur trois parce que des
études qui ont été faites à paris soit
disant dans des rues et on en a huit sur
dix qui avait payé donc ça on n'est pas
tout à fait sûr mais ce qui est surtout
c'est que ça met dans une myriade
d'augmentation pour l'automobile pour
les français et c'est un un coût
supplémentaire il faut bien le dire de
toute façon et c'est à dire que pour
vous les autonomistes sont vertueux par
rapport à l'horodateur
on n'attend pas des automobilistes en
ont des français d'accord mais dès qu'on
dit oui mais on est tous à un moment
donné au volant d'une voiture roulant
avec un vélo aujourd'hui la mobilité
elle est multiple dont talent des
français et c'est un coût supplémentaire
malheureusement ce sont des taxes
supplémentaires pour les français dont
je vous fais un petit peu plus des
parkings non plusieurs à deux parcs alan
faut voir ça faut pas voir ça comme ça
par exemple dans paris pendant paris je
connais pas trop l'exemple de poissy
mais il ya à peu près 20% ça c'est une
estimation qui est très claire de
voitures qui tournent en permanence pour
trouver une place
faciliter le parking de ses voitures et
vous avez 20 % de circulation au moins
20% bouchons en moins et ça circulait
c'est une approche différente et là le
problème justement c'est poussé à les
payer et notamment pour vous si jusqu'à
présent qu'une fois je me réfère aux
chiffres notamment de la cour des
comptes si selon eux deux automobilistes
sur trois ne veulent pas payer ne payent
pas leur place de parking parce qu'il
dise toute façon je veux pas de prix
qu'est ce qui vous fait dire que vous
avez amélioré justement ce contrôle est
ce que justement c'était plutôt un
cadeau empoisonné que ça va vous pousser
à avoir encore plus de frais à embaucher
des personnes ou à utiliser une société
privée comment vous allez faire
exactement
la vérité c'est avez raison c'est que
cette réforme on s'en serait bien passé
à poissy et ailleurs pourquoi parce que
hier il y avait effectivement des agents
de sécurité de la voie publique par
exemple des policiers municipaux qui
pouvait dresser entre guillemets des pv
et puis l'amande était confiée à l'état
qu'il agirait aujourd'hui c'est plus le
cas aujourd'hui certes les recettes vont
dans les caisses de la ville
finalement les amendes devant dans les
caisses des collectivités territoriales
les ep c'est donc les communautés
urbaines les communautés d'agglomération
la communauté urbaine grand paris seine
et oise concernant poissy par exemple au
coeur des 73 autres communes de bais de
mes collègues
pourquoi je dis cela parce que vous
l'avez dit il faut surveiller ces
véhicules est aujourd'hui dans une ville
de 40 mille habitants vous avez un
hypercentre qui est aujourd'hui saturée
faut simplement trouver et envoyer des
messages
comment allez-vous faire ce que vous
avez embauché à n'ont certainement pas
pour moi c'est un espèce de
désengagement supplémentaire de l'état
on envoie la patate chaude au niveau des
collectivités et débrouillez-vous en
échange de quoi
plutôt que de gérer effectivement le
fruit collectées par les amendes
on va les envoyer au comité urbaine donc
finalement c'est vraiment une patate
chaude c'est un bâton c'est un bâton
merdeux parce que justement il n'ya pas
aussi une sorte pourquoi je dis ça
oui parce qu'il faut vulgariser le
message auprès nos administrés je
rejoins ce que je dis vive car à nos
administrés aujourd'hui notamment je
pense aux personnes âgées aujourd'hui
vouloir demander d'inscrire la plaque
d'immatriculation d'avoir un système de
maximum ou de 2 minimum à l'arrivée vous
avez des gens je pense notamment aux
personnes âgées je parle pas des
commerçants parce que la vérité
les salariés des commerces souvent avec
le mm pourtant là on parle bien de
parkings payants qui est censé être
auparavant ce qui se passait séparément
qu'est-ce que je me serais plus là
aujourd'hui la question c'est que
normalement pour moi il y avait une
carotte et un bâton c'est à dire que
ou décider notamment du montant de ce
fps et vous récupérez ce que vous pensez
que penser qu'en mettant à mon temps à
17 euros à 10 euros à 30 euros à 35
euros ça va dissuader les gens les les
français vous leur faites payer deux
euros supplémentaires
ces deux euros de trop donc c'est
effectivement il faut des règles il faut
payer et c'est comme ça il ya des règles
du jeu les personnes qui ne payent pas
hier ne paieront pas plus demain faut
simplement les accompagnent et je pense
que ça n'a pas été suffisamment dans la
vulgarisation du message au même titre
que d'autres réformes je pense notamment
aux emplois aidés
on sait que ce n'était pas une bonne une
mauvaise idée mais on a pris ça
brusquement en plein été il faut
accompagner nous faut revenir sur les
mesures de décentralisation qui vous a
deux justement avoir une politique de la
vie de la voiture en ville alors la
seule chose c'est que ça nous aide parce
qu'on va récupérer des recettes
supplémentaires
in fine et via les collectivités
urbaines la communauté urbaine mais en
l'occurrence à quel prix ça nous aide
parce que je peux vous dire que depuis
le 1er janvier les collègues élus les
administrés passent leur temps on
apporte et d'engueulades on est à portée
envers ils ne comprennent pas c'est
exactement ce que j'allais dire que
c'est une patate chaude pour les élus et
ça va être une charge terry parce que
quand vous prenez dans notre ville tout
le monde à vous demander tu peux pas me
faire sauter la prime tu peux pas faire
si pour eux ça va être une charge
supplémentaire il n'avait pas besoin de
ça parce que j'ai déjà beaucoup de
choses ça rentre dans le cadre d'un
désengagement de l'état et après
effectivement la suspicion auprès des
communes sérieux ça va être une ligne
budgétaire mais si cette ligne
budgétaire cyr vraiment pour les
infrastructures pour améliorer ou
pourquoi pas faire une journée gratuite
un jour où ou un somnifère à améliorer
on sait pas comment ça va être géré mais
ce qui est sûr c'est que ça va être une
charge supplémentaire et pour les élus
c'est pas simple à gérer ça va pas être
simple à gérer
ce forfait post au stationnement donc
c'est une décentralisation malvenu à ce
sujet ah oui je pense que il faut
prioriser en l'occurrence parmi les
priorités moi j'aurais préféré par
exemple qu'on vienne travailler sur un
contrat gagnant gagnant sur la gestion
financière des collectivités locales
impossible par exemple depuis quatre ans
on génère 5 millions d'euros d'économies
de budget de fonctionnement moins par
rapport à d'autres communes
il n'y a pas à juger de gauche comme de
droite qui sont largement dans le rouge
et j'ai la même dotation d'état qui
baisse par rapport aux mauvaises
ça c'est paris va pas vous aider
notamment avoir une autre politique de
la voiture en ville
non pas du tout parce que je pense
qu'aujourd'hui évidemment qu'il faut
qu'on a un usage différent du véhicule
il s'agit pas d'arrêter le véhicule
il s'agit peut-être de mieux de mieux
l'utiliser moi je suis un fervent
défenseur du tram du tramway que nous
souhaitons installer à poissy en
insertion urbaine parce que je veux
envoyer un message aux jeunes et aux
moins jeunes qu'au pied de chez eux
plutôt que de prendre le véhicule pour
faire 4 km ils peuvent prendre le
tramway ça c'est des usages qui sont
importants pour réduire le trafic de
transit comme on peut le connaître à
poissy avec 20 % de trafic en moins
via ce tramway aujourd'hui on va pas
gommer la voiture on en a on en a
évidemment besoin
il ya d'autres sortes de véhicules vous
n'avez pas essayé notamment d'essayer de
faire payer notamment les places de
parking recevrez tous c'est quand même
vous qui décidez sur une place et
payantes ou pas et la femme à moitié
pour une chose pas si chez moi après si
nous avons des des parcs de des parcs
relais par exemple qui seront gratuits
et puis tout ce qui concerne les zones
d'hyper sentent effectivement c est
payant parce qu'il s'agit effectivement
de faire de la rotation par rapport à ce
qu'on appelle les voitures ventouses qui
tous les jours sont toujours installés
au même endroit au même moment et c'est
avec des tickets qui qui sont qui sont
renouvelés je pense qu'il faut
simplement clarifier vraiment les règles
et encore une fois l'objectif c'est pas
dépénalisées comme 10 carats l'instant
est allé taper dans le portefeuille des
français donc je crois que c'est pas le
geste très fort non tout n'est pas à
jeter parce que comme le disait karl
olive
il faut un petit peu moins de voiture
mangée surtout qu'il faut mieux de
voitures donc il faut organiser quelque
chose qui s'est développée pendant un
siècle et que ce soit dans les villes
petites moyennes ou à cette réforme
n'est ce pas justement à mieux contrôler
l'afflux de voitures il faut mettre des
moyens des moyens supplémentaires que ce
soit une répression fait clément terre
en fait il faut que ce soit organisé
et pourquoi pas mais c'est bien alors
les mairies découvre ça aussi c'est une
force supplémentaire va falloir qu'ils
apprennent à gérer mais peut-être que
vous aurez une bonne surprise finalement
que les gens paieront peut-être un petit
peu plus que ce sera une ligne
budgétaire 15 jours pourrait vous dire
on va faire une journée gratuite dont on
va surveiller ça l'automobile club
association on est d'ailleurs les
collectivités qui veulent nous appeler
pour avoir des renseignements ou des
aides il n'y a pas de souci mais il faut
surveiller simplement cette modification
qui je le répète rentre dans un cadre
2018 terrible pour les automobilistes
français donc pour tous les français
très bas ce sera la fin de cette
émission merci à vous en tout cas
d'avoir accepté de participer merci à
vous vous pouvez voir et revoir cette
émission sur notre site internet je vous
souhaite une agréable soirée et à la
semaine prochaine sur notre antenne
[Musique]